Is the hijab 10 discount code for 10%
discount on a wide range of products
including premium Ethiopian black seed
products. So, I was watching um an
interesting podcast uh between Logan
Paul or conversation between Logan Paul
and Mike Tyson
in his uh Impulsive uh
podcast.
And some really interesting themes came
up.
I'm I'm afraid to to die. This
particular moment in my life,
early 20s, I didn't I wasn't afraid of
death. I didn't I didn't care. And now
at 25, I do. I want to be around for a
long time.
I don't know. What's What's your concept
of death? I don't know. I don't know. I
think it's uh my conscious sentient
No, what you need to do, brother?
leaving
to You need to study the concept of
death. Is there books on it? Oh, you
think it's not looking at the company.
Yeah. But which one is right? Because no
one no one really knows what happens
when you die.
up to you. That's up to you that die you
sick. So, as you guys saw there, it was
really interesting to see them talking
about death,
talking about, you know, the fear of
death in the case of Logan Paul where he
was saying that he fears death, and then
talking about religious books.
And I find death a really fascinating
subject. And the reason why is because
it's something which all of us are going
to experience and none of us who are
alive have experienced. If you think
about that, that's really
um shocking reality that all of us are
going to die and none of us have
experienced this uh death.
I also find it interesting to compare
death with sleep. Not least because from
the Islamic perspective, they're seen as
comparable. The prophet said that, you
know, sleep is the brother of uh death.
And the reason why, if you think about
it, is because both sleep and death
feature a common characteristic, which
is that one loses consciousness in both
uh of those states. In your sleep state,
you lose consciousness temporarily.
Uh
and then you're regained with
consciousness. And likewise, we believe
as as Muslims that you lose
consciousness in death, but you gain it
in a different realm or different
reality or different state.
Uh and just like in the same way as you
would be sleeping, okay, and dreaming.
And so that in a sense you're not
looking at anything, but you are
experiencing something else.
When you are dead, your conscious state
does not is not lost, but it's just
transferred to a different reality.
And it's a reality where in which you'll
be questioned.
There's judgment. Um and then you'll be
uh
questioned very specific questions,
quite frankly, about what you believed
in. And uh then you're resurrected, we
believe as Muslims, and uh questioned
about what you've done in your life and
whatever good you've done, you'll see it
then. Whatever bad you've done, you'll
see it then.
But the second question of which book is
true, because obviously now the question
of what's your theory of death, what is
your eschatology. And then the question
of what book is right. And so therefore,
because these are metaphysical points
and quite frankly, you wouldn't be
obliged to believe in any of this
without there being some kind of
anchorage, intellectual anchorage that
gave us proof and evidence
for its veracity and for its robustness
and for its truth, which could then
expound upon these points. And quite
frankly,
the question of examination is at the
fore of these discussions, because
Mike Tyson was right. You need to be
able to uh dissect to use the words.
We could use the word decipher or
distinguish or examine the different
texts that are available. The Quran, the
Bible, the Old Testament, New Testament,
which obviously comprises the
The Bible is comprised of. Then, you
know, the Bhagavad Gita, the GGS, all of
those books.
Examination, and to see which of those
books is the true one, if there is in
fact one that is true at all.
And I think this is
something which should be at the front
of our minds in terms of exploration.
And so, I would I would put you that
when you're examining
or dissecting these books,
that you should have standards in place.
And I'll give you something which I
believe
are both necessary
and also sufficient
in order for you
to be able to make a decision
of which book out there, religious book,
is the is the correct one.
So So, in terms of necessary conditions,
I say that there are books out there
that must conform to at least two or
three major points in order to be
uh the word of God or the truth.
The necessary conditions for a book
being the word of God or the truth is
that this book cannot be
uh
something which is not preserved to our
day. In other words, the book has to be
preserved. It's not something which was,
for example, a book that existed uh a
long time ago and it doesn't exist now.
The central message has to be preserved.
The book itself has to be preserved,
such that
the access that the original recipients
of that book have to that book is the
same access
that we have to that book. Otherwise,
it's not universal.
You see? So, the first condition which I
believe is a necessary condition for
something being the word of God or the
truth, is preservation.
A second one is lack of contradictions.
Because if you have contradictions
that this thing, whatever it is, that's
making a claim,
is false, because something which is
true
cannot have contradictions within it.
Moreover, it cannot be be something that
anyone can make. In other words, there
has to be
a kind of inimitability
of this, whatever it is. Because if it's
something which can be easily
replicated, then what is special about
it in the first place?
And now I think we're segueing from
necessary conditions in order for
something to be the word of God
to what I would say is sufficient or
sufficient conditions.
So now,
I would say, if a book has all those
three things, is is perfectly preserved,
it's um
free from contradictions,
and it's
inimitable.
I think now we have the necessary
conditions required for that book to be
from God.
For it to be sufficient now, we have to
make a probabilistic case,
meaning we have to see the evidences
that are presented from this book.
You see,
the Quran says
Inna nazalna dhikra wa inna lahu la
hafizun. We have certainly sent down the
book and we will certainly preserve it
in chapter 15 verse 9.
And the Quran says
in chapter 4 verse 81
that if this book was from other than
God, la wajadu fihi ikhtilafan kathira,
they would have found in it many
contradictions.
And the Quran says
that fa'tu bi suratin min mithlihi wa
da'u shuhada'akum min duni Allahi in
kuntum sadiqeen. That if this book was
from other than God, then produce
something like it, and bring your
witnesses from other than God,
or uh
if you are indeed truthful,
in chapter 2 verse 27.
So these are the sufficient conditions.
The necessary Sorry, the necessary the
sufficient conditions
are things now where we start to see the
evidence cuz the Quran says
say bring your evidences if you're
truthful.
And so what evidences are we talking
about?
The Islamic corpus has a range of
evidences.
For example, prophecies of the future.
Prophecies of the future are
particularly interesting
because
if you have prophecies of the future
that indicates
that the the the the person who is
making these prophecies can either be
guessing or making these prophecies from
some kind of knowledge. And who knows
the future except for
an all-knowing entity.
Except for an all-knowing entity that
knows the details of the future.
So you see
prophecies of the future are one of the
many ways
in which Islam uses to verify itself.
And I'm not going to mention all the
prophecies, but I'm going to mention two
or three just to wet your appetite.
One of them is that the Quran mentions
in chapter 30 verses 1 to 6 that the
Romans had been defeated in a nearby and
lowland.
And that they will become successful
from three to nine years.
And this is referring to an event that
took place between the Roman Empire and
the Persian Empire.
And you see the Quran is very specific
when it comes to times and places. And
this is not the first and only time or
the Islamic tradition is very specific
about future events. There are literally
dozens, scores of examples of this.
And that I will refer you to a book
called The Forbidden Prophecies
which you can download for free in the
description box.
In addition to this, Islam has a very
precise way of verifying itself from a
historical perspective.
Historical things which couldn't have
been known
because certain discoveries had not been
made
are mentioned in the Quran.
And I will leave in the description box
a video which if you're interested on
what I'm talking about, you can watch so
you can see what I'm saying.
In addition to this, you'll find that
the Arabic language that is being used
the Quran is revealed in,
it completely de-scopes that which had
previously come
from Arabic um poetry and so on and so
forth.
And thus it completely dumbfounded the
Arabs of the time and bedazzled the very
um
the the the the very elite of the poets
that existed in that time.
And so from all of those perspectives
and more, we say we have a way
in which and through by
we can actually verify Islam
and prove that it is
the correct religion
and that the Quran and the Sunnah
or the Quran and the tradition of the
prophet
is in fact the guidance from God,
the same God that created us, the one
creator God
which we call Allah.
Was salaam alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.